in today's video we'll be explaining all
s-class heroes in one punch man we'll
start with the puri puri prisoner who's
ranked lowest in s-class and in the
later parts of the video we'll cover
much more interesting and mysterious
characters being an s-class hero puri
puri prisoner is a very powerful
individual he's able to blow holes in
the body of a dragon level monster and
deal minor damage to the deep sea king
however while powerful he self-proclaims
himself to be the weakest s-class hero
this is shown at the beginning of the
series when he had difficulty fighting
some demon level monsters the pudipuri
prisoner possesses immense physical
strength as seen when he easily breaks
through the thick steel walls of the
smelly lid prison he was able to defeat
the demon level free hugger merely by
hugging it with excessive force having
become stronger he also defeated a
monster as powerful as the deep sea king
by using the killing technique he
learned from him during his battle
against bakuma a demon level monster
that absorbed the power of other
monsters in its vicinity puripuri
prisoner was able to easily obliterate
the monster with his vibrating dark
angel rush technique he also possesses
impressive toughness and is much more
durable than average heroes he was able
to endure some strikes from deep sea
king a powerful demon level monster only
going down later in the fight after
getting stronger his durability was
notably increased as he easily withstood
a blow from even stronger monsters his
skin was also so tough that even razor
blades couldn't penetrate additionally
puri puri prisoner was durable enough to
survive attacks from dragon level
threats such as nyan and garu though he
was seriously injured there are still 16
more characters left to cover and trust
me you don't want to miss a single one
number 16 tank top master tank top
master often simply called master is the
s-class rank 16 professional hero of the
hero association he's the leader of the
tank topper army as an s-class hero he's
one of the strongest heroes in the
association and one of the physically
strongest men on the planet in his fight
with garu he could not only harm garu
but also hold the upper hand against the
hero hunter for the majority of the
fight garu noted that tank top master's
physical strength equal that of genos
with the upgrade however against the
dragon level executives of the monster
association tank top master was helpless
and overpowered by fewer ugly and gums
his incredible physical abilities can be
seen when he hurled a large concrete
block at a great distance towards the
dark matter thieves spacecraft he was
able to break apart and shake the ground
with a single punch causing garu to lose
his balance momentarily he also defeated
the monster joffrey by sending it flying
through a wall with a tackle despite
still recovering from his injuries from
the fight with garrow his incredible
strength is once again shown when he
lifts and throws a transmission tower
through the air at incredible speed
amazing the other heroes standing nearby
with such a performance he continued to
show great powers in his throwing
abilities as he was able to hurl large
chunks of rubble and eventually even a
building albeit with the help of fubuki
who enhanced his physical prowess his
style of fighting consists of several
punches and wrestling moves however as
garrow evaluates tank top master mainly
relies on power rather than technique
the next one on our list is bad better
known by his hero alias metalbat he's a
member of the hero association and
currently serves as s-class rank 15
professional hero despite his lower rank
he's a powerful and intimidating
combatant as he was able to hold his own
against garrow one of the strongest
characters on the entire show he's
exceptionally hardy capable of taking on
multiple demon level monsters
simultaneously he has also stood up to
dragon class monsters managing to cause
elder centipede considerable pain with
his swings metal bat possesses immense
physical strength and has taken out very
powerful monsters and villains with a
single bat swing this includes two demon
level monsters and even senior centipede
whose care space can withstand
generosity's incineration cannon despite
being unable to break elder centipede's
incredible tough carapace he did push
the giant monster down and completely
stopped it in his tracks it's noted that
his fighting spirit heightens his
strength as garrow observed that the
longer the fight drags on the more
powerful metal bat becomes to the point
that he can easily destroy buildings and
tear the ground apart causing powerful
shock waves garrow even complimented him
and stating that he would have lost the
fight if he had received even a single
strike from the bat during his fight
with sage centipede metal bat's fighting
spirit eventually increased his strength
to the point that he together with an
evolved aguero was able to damage and
crack the giant monster's tough carapace
which was more durable than that of
elder centipede despite this metal bat's
sheer strength was inferior to the hero
hunters by a large margin and his
attacks were momentarily amplified by
garros number 14 genos now on to one of
the show's main characters saitama
sidekick genos he's a 19 year old cyborg
and the disciple of saitama he always
aims to become more powerful and he
fights for justice under the hero
association he's given the name demon
cyborg and is currently s-class rank 14.
genos possesses incredible physical
strength and can break apart the ground
with a dropkick and punch with enough
force to tear apart a cliff face during
his brief fight with the deep-sea king
he was able to land a full force punch
on the creature that sent it flying
through the wall in his fight with gero
guerrero noted that his strength rivaled
that of tank top master his entire body
has been replaced with combat-ready
cybernetics and prosthesis giving him an
extreme level of strength and speed and
advanced sensors and projectile attacks
genus is very agile and he can move so
fast that he appears to be teleporting
as a result he was able to keep up with
sonic for a considerable amount of time
in their battle with both moving faster
than sound and fubuki unable to follow
their movements at all genos can
continue fighting without much drawback
even after the parts of his body are
destroyed due to most of his body being
artificial he appears to have an
extremely high tolerance to injuries due
to him not being able to feel pain for
the most part however given the
expression on his face after making
contact with a deep-sea king's acid spit
it could be assumed that he feels pain
for the direct acidic corrosion of his
body besides this he does not often show
significant signs of physical stress
you're probably wondering how is there
13 more powerful characters than jenos
well stick to the end and find out who
these characters are number 13 flashy
flash flashy flash is the s-class rank
13 professional hero of the hero
association he is a former member of the
ninja village's 44th graduation class
nicknamed the end besides his massive
physical strength he's arguably the
fastest s-class hero in the association
flashy flash is also one of the few
s-class heroes capable of defeating
multiple dragon level monsters
single-handedly he is set to kill
enemies like a flash of light before
they can sense what happened his speed
leaves powerful shock waves in his wake
during the initial attack on the monster
association flashy flash dispatched some
monsters so quickly that even shadow
ring a fellow ninja could not see what
happened he effortlessly kept up with
two demon level monsters known for
having remarkable speed hellfire flame
and gail win he only felt some pressure
when they transformed into the dragon
level forms but was still able to kick
them at a speed they could not counter
after stunning them with a barrage of
fast kicks he managed to cross a great
distance and perform one of his ultimate
techniques slicing the two monsters in
half before they could even react his
actions were so fast that they seemed to
happen almost simultaneously flashy
flash's speed was also remarkable enough
to impress saitama with the latter
stating that he was kind of fast during
his fight against an evolved aguero the
two fighters were combating each other
at extreme speeds a geometric structure
of light was even created from their
blinding movements flashy flash is also
a very analytical fighter he
strategically waited for the right
moment to incapacitate gail wind and
hellfire flame simultaneously to prevent
either from escaping reasoning that the
other heroes would have trouble dealing
with their speed number 12 watchdog man
the next hero on our list is literally a
guy dressed up in a dog costume but make
no mistake because watchdog man is one
of the most powerful heroes in the
entire organization a testament to his
prowess is that he was left in charge of
queue city considered the most dangerous
city in terms of monsters numbers and
average disaster level he's also
described to eliminate monsters like no
other in his early days as a hero he
managed to rip off the head of an
enormous monster without incurring an
injury watchdog manages extremely fast
able to rip apart multiple monsters
within a few seconds despite being
surrounded by 30 monsters of monster
association watchdog man managed to
quickly defeat all of them and come out
of the battle without a scratch
surprising gero who was watching the
fight furthermore he could easily keep
up with and block all attacks from
garrow during their fight and retaliated
at a speed that the hero hunter was
unable to counter garrow himself even
commented that watchdog man's speed far
exceeded his expectations watchdog man's
fighting style was described by garrow
as that of a beast or a monster rather
than a human garrow also noted that
watchdog man lacks any special
techniques or weapons relying only on
simple hand to hand combat furthermore
because gyro's techniques are designed
against human targets not animals
watchdog man can counter all the hero
hunter's movements perfectly number 11
super alloy dark shine dark shine is
arguably the physically strongest hero
in the whole hero association he
rightfully so holds the position of
s-class rank 11 hero his defense is
stated to be number one in the hero
world dark shine has trained his muscles
in a completely different fashion than
take top master and puripuri prisoner
his impressive muscles act as a type of
pseudo armor displaying a masterful
combination of hardness strength and
toughness making him seem to be nearly
indestructible dark shine could
withstand the fall of heavy and large
debris of crumbly buildings completely
unfazed while looking back at mizuki he
was able to talk to her while getting
repeatedly attacked by multiple monsters
in front of him taking no damage
whatsoever against the demon level
monster the bug god darkshine was able
to effortlessly sustain attacks from the
monster before and after it transformed
even darkshine himself can't think of a
way he could be injured he is durable
enough to withstand attacks from dragon
level monsters touches garrow before the
hero hunter started evolving again he
was also able to block the brunt of
force behind a barrage of attacks from
garrow's cross fang dragon slayer fist
however eventually gero evolved to the
point of causing dark shine to cough of
blood and have a slight nose bleed
despite being beat down by a nearly
evolved gyro his body remained
practically unscathed dark shine also
received the full brunt of evil natural
waters jet streams and only remarked
that it was a nice shower darkshine's
immensely durable body also allowed him
to resist gum's stomach acid which can
almost instantly digest debris albeit he
still felt pain and was burning his skin
he would only be beaten due to his fear
of being defeated and his insecurities
rather than actual physical damage
number 10 pig god pig is definitely a
unique hero and the hero we know very
little about he is the s-class rank 10
professional hero and therefore
considered to be among the top 10 heroes
in the entire world like other heroes of
that class he is able to defeat demon
level monsters on his own as he proved
with his swift and effortless victory
against eyesight and the great food tub
pig god has the ability to digest
swallowed monsters almost instantly he
also seems to have complete control over
his digestive system since despite the
strength of gastric acid he was able to
store atomic samurai's three disciples
safely in his belly and smit them out
unharmed his body can expand greatly
without tearing apart or bursting open
this allows pig god to consume monsters
much larger than himself this is first
seen when eating eyesight as he managed
to stuff her into his mouth by
stretching his lips very wide pigot's
body bulks up due to the monster's
larger size without any visible signs of
pain he was able to force gums a dragon
level monster to spit him out after
swallowing him he also managed to
briefly go toe-to-toe with the monster
but ultimately lost rather quickly
number 9 drive knight drive knight is a
very powerful individual and is the
s-class rank 9 professional hero of the
hero association he easily defeated a
group of tiger level monsters and he
managed to defeat the dragon level
monster nian relatively quickly and
without sustaining much damage however
he admitted that he won only because
nyan was overconfident and reckless he
had already collected battle data
beforehand which allowed him to gain the
upper hand secondgaar has claimed that
drive knight has never lost a battle
before this reputation is enough to
cause worry for the hero association
when the possibility of his defeat is
presented drive night's fighting style
consists of transforming multiple times
during a fight depending on the number
of monsters involved and on the strength
of each monster individually the speed
of each transformation does not seem to
be an inconvenience as it appears to
occur almost instantaneously like geno's
drive knight's body is powered by an
energy core when drive knight's energy
reserves are depleted he can fuse with
another cyborg or robot to access their
energy course thus allowing maximum
energy output number 8 zombie man zombie
man is the s-class rank 8 professional
hero and a product of the house of
evolution he is one of the few people
aware of saitama's power he's currently
aiming to become just as powerful as him
zombie man wears a special trench coat
that possesses unique properties
allowing him to carry many different
weapons with him at all times he is
shown using various handguns with
excellent proficiency and some close
range weapons described as a man that
even in death cannot die zombie man
possesses the best regeneration
capabilities in the series he can
regenerate any part of his body no
matter how severe the injury is for
example he was able to fully regenerate
from having a hole in his head and
broken arms in a few seconds even if he
is beheaded or his organs explode zombie
man will not die but will even
regenerate from such fatal injuries his
regeneration is so fast that one of
pureblood's bats could not escape his
flesh before zombie man fully healed
even after having parts of his body
incinerated by homeless emperor's energy
spheres zombie man was still capable of
fully regenerating albeit it may take
him quite a bit of time to recover there
was even a time he himself thought he
was dead however this regeneration does
not give zombie man complete immortality
as he will die if he is reduced to
mincemeat number 7 king now on to the
fan favorite and one of the funniest
heroes in the s-class king king is the
s-class rank 7 professional hero in
public king is known as the strongest
man on earth and hero's hero in truth
however he is just an average civilian
who unintentionally gained credit for
the heroic acts performed by saitama
king is also part of the saitama group
his status has resulted in being
targeted by assassins who are paid vast
sums of money by crime bosses
fortunately all assassins sent after him
are just as delusional as ordinary
people in perceiving king's false power
so they often think that they're
targeting the formidable foe and are
willing to give up when king peacefully
confronts them king's intimidating
presence while near the defeated
monsters gave the hero association the
false impression that he was strong king
in reality has never brawled before in
his life meaning he is the weakest
person in this class if not the entire
hero association his intimidating
characteristics also have no effect on
robotic opponents it should be noted
that his hero title does not fail to
describe his video game accomplishments
he is an expert at video games and has
won some video game tournaments in his
youth this talent later proves helpful
when king saves saitama who
irresponsibly signed a contract without
reading it fubuki forcibly wanted to
have saitama bang jenos and king join
the blizzard group should they win the
bet outlined in the contract the bet was
decided with video games and king
defeated 30 gamers by himself he can
also write scripts about video game
content since he often works on creating
an independent game during weekends it's
safe to say that king is a different
kind of hero but that's why he's one of
the fan favorites number 6 bullfoy dr
bofoy also known by his hero alias metal
knight is the s-class rank 6 hero of the
hero association he offers many services
for the hero association such as weapons
sponsorships and facility construction
being an s-class hero it can be assumed
that bullfoy is very powerful however he
got that position due to his brainpower
and the strength of his weapons instead
of his own physical strength according
to georgioro he is one of the four
heroes that could beat elder centipede
despite this he was unable to damage the
monster when he fought it with his drone
however it is noted that the full extent
of bolfoy's military might and weaponry
is unknown even to the hero association
this is why they fear his potential
betrayal as he would pose a huge threat
according to child emperor the power of
the weapons bolfoy possesses is beyond
that of any lone hero bofoy is said to
have a reputation for using powerful
weaponry to pulverize his opponents and
everything else in its vicinity he uses
various remotely controlled robots for
his missions and experiments equipped
for the occasion with this form of
combat bofoid doesn't put his own life
at stake as he controls his robots from
a safe distance number 5 child emperor
despite his young age child emperor is a
genius he has a very analytical mind and
is capable of observing situations and
formulating plans in a calm and
collected manner he managed to become
s-class rank 5 hero only at the age of
10 proving how powerful he is however
his high rank in the s-class is
primarily due to his brain power instead
of physical strength through tactics and
his gadgets he can defeat numerous
monsters on his own whether through
guerrilla warfare or prepared head-on
combat like his fellow s-class heroes
child emperor is strong enough to handle
a demon level monster on his own and
with relative ease however unlike most
of his allies who use direct force to
fight he fights with intellect and
strength preferring to create
opportunities preparations and
strategies to put the odds in his favor
and defeat his opponents instead of
using muscle power and raw speed child
emperor can also hold his own against a
dragon level monster by himself however
he seems to struggle a great deal
against them he admitted that had
phoenix man used an alternate form of
attack against him it would have ended
badly for him he was only able to defeat
phoenix man by using his intellect
exposing his opponent's weakness and
destroying his costume his value and
strength are in his brains and that's
why he's ranked five number four
kamikaze kamikaze better known by his
hero alias atomic samurai is the s-class
rank four professional hero he's a
swordmaster and a member of the council
of swordmasters atomic samurai is an
extremely formidable swordsman so much
so that he's considered the earth's
strongest swordsman legend even says
that he can cut down over 100 enemies
with a single strike his sword attacks
are so fast and intense that the enemies
are slashed into many pieces instantly
without even be able to react he was
also able to cut a monster to bits using
a mere toothpick he was capable of
countering many of malzagar's attacks
which were extremely quick in their own
right his fantastic speed was showcased
once again when he defeated a
transformed haragiri who claimed to be
faster than the speed of sound he
managed to draw a sword and slash him
dozens of times so quickly that hiragiri
appeared to have not moved at all
shortly before dying his sword drawing
speed is so fast that even sonic could
not see its execution he was capable of
slicing rhino wrestler a demon level
monster so fast that it appeared like he
did not even draw his sword the monster
assumed he had not attacked and was
still talking for a few seconds before
turning into smithereens only three
characters left and trust me these ones
are on an entirely different level than
the others number three bang bang also
known by his hero alias silverfang is a
professional hero a martial arts master
and the creator and teacher of water
stream rock smashing fist bang possesses
incredible physical strength despite his
old age far beyond that of an average
hero even by s-class standards he is the
third highest-ranked hero of the hero
association and is recognized as one of
its most powerful heroes in his youth he
was nicknamed wind of blood another of
bang's achievement is that he trained
garrow who was also incredibly strong
himself gyro stated that demon level
monsters like bug god and royal ripper
are nothing compared to his former
master he is known as an idol and
treasurer of martial arts almost like a
god in the martial arts world bang's
combination of immense physical power
and vast martial arts prowess makes him
one of the most powerful close range
fighters in the hero association his
amazing strength was demonstrated during
his fight against gums and fear her ugly
two dragon level monsters capable of
kicking through the former and thrashing
the latter without much effort
additionally despite gero constantly
improving and evolving bang has still
proved capable of fighting on equal
footing with him for a considerable
amount of time before finally being
defeated combining his strength with his
big brother bang knocked elder centipede
back and destroyed the enormous
monster's carapace armor which is
durable enough to withstand metal
knight's missiles and metal bat swings
without a scratch he was also able to
overpower garrow in hand-to-hand combat
before he evolved almost killing his
former student and proving how powerful
he is number two tatsumaki tatsumaki is
the character we've got to see quite a
few times so far in the series and she's
regarded as the strongest esper in the
entire world with her psychokinetic
abilities she was capable of
effortlessly stopping a very powerful
bombardment attack from boroso's giant
spaceship and sending them back at the
ship with the same if not more force
according to the one punch man's manga
artist tatsumaki can lift the entirety
of z city in a brief fight against
hundred eye octopus an enormous demon
level monster the size of a skyscraper
she effortlessly sent the monster in the
air and crushed it into a ball with her
telekinesis power at full power she was
able to lift the entire monster
association headquarters out of the
ground while simultaneously shielding
multiple other heroes inside the
facility after finally being able to go
wild tatsumaki was shown to have
absolute dominance over the fusion of
psychos and orochi capable of completely
stopping one of fusion monster's
strongest energy attacks in its tracks
and tossing it away despite the attack
apparently containing enough power to
cut through the earth's surface she was
then able to restrain the fusion entity
to the point that it could not even move
a finger before destroying most of its
gigantic body by telekinetically
twisting it causing the entire z city to
distort and finally the strongest hero
in the entire hero association the
mighty blast although he is the s-class
rank 1 hero we don't know much about him
because he always goes to various places
to collect the mysterious cubes which is
a hobby of his he also revealed that
there are multiple of these cubes in
various places and they act as a
transmitter to communicate with god who
he refers to as him moreover the cubes
are able to distort the space and time
within their vicinity he possesses
immense levels of physical strength
easily able to carry around the
mysterious cube even casually spinning
it on his fingertip in a playful fashion
meanwhile this cube is heavy enough to
cause flashy flash's arm to get stuck
under it and sink into the ground upon
being tossed away by sagdama he also
possesses the ability to generate
portals which allows him to move through
another dimension or transfer objects we
first witnessed this when he generated a
portal to get flashy flash and saitama
out of the cave he clapped his fists
together and an infinity symbol appeared
across his fists we don't know much
about his fights with monsters but we do
know that he was able to bring elder
centipede a dragon level threat to the
brink of death we can't wait to see
blast's unique abilities in the future
and how his story will impact the one
punch man world click on this video
where we rank all titan shifters in
attack on titan go on click it